there are occasions as gwendaline
remarked in The Importance of Being
Earnest when it becomes more than a
moral duty to speak one's mind it
becomes a pleasure
and this is one such occasion with my
trusty hitch by my side I am very proud
to be here but also very nervous very
worried I've been nervous all day and
the reason I've been nervous is quite
simple and that is that this motion
matters to me it matters to me greatly
it's not a joke it's not a game it's not
just a debate I genuinely believe that
the Catholic church is not to put it at
its mildest a Force for good in the
world and therefore it is important for
me to try and Marshall my facts as well
I can to explain why I think that but I
want first of all to say that I have no
quarrel and no argument and I wish to
express no contempt for individual
devout and Pious men members of that
church they are welcome to their
sacraments to their welcome to their
reliquaries and to their Blessed Virgin
Mary they're welcome to their um to
their faith to the importance they place
in it to the comfort and the joy that
they receive from it all of that is
absolutely fine by me it would be
impertinent and wrong of me to express
any antagonism towards any individual
who wishes to find Salvation in whatever
form they wish to express it that to me
is sacran as much as any Article of
Faith is sacran to anyone of any church
or any faith in the world it's very
important it's also very important to me
is it happens um that I have my own
beliefs they are a belief in the
enlightenment they are a belief um in
the Eternal adventure of trying to
discover moral truth in the world
discover it's a terribly important word
to which we might return it's a fight
it's an empirical fight it's one that
was begun in the middle of uh of of the
last Millennium uh it's given the name
the Enlightenment and there is nothing
sadly that the Catholic church and its
hierarchs likes to do more than to
attack the enlightenment it did so at
the time reference was made to Galileo
and the fact that he was tortured for
trying to explain the cernic theory of
the
universe that's history history as Miss
Wham has reminded us is irrelevant it's
not important all that matters now is
that billions of pounds go out of this
extraordinary institution to relieve the
poor around the world and make the world
a better place history is of no
importance whatsoever well I beg to
differ
history history wines and quivers and
vibrates in all of us in this Hall in
this square mile let's think about this
square mile I'll come back to it in a
moment but first Christopher made
mention of limbo it seems so tedious and
so silly one of those little casuistic
games that toist and others play ainus
and Augustine of Hippo both proposed
this extraordinary idea that babies who
were unbaptized would not know Heaven
they also proposed the idea of purgatory
which doesn't exist in the Bible there's
absolutely no evidence for it however
what an extraordinary brilliant coup to
imagine such a thing as per Tre that a
soul needs to be prayed
for in order to go to heaven in order to
turn left when he enters the airplane of
heaven and get a first class
seat that he needs to be prayed for and
for many hundreds indeed over a thousand
years you'll be amazed what generous
terms those prayers came at sometimes as
little are as 2third of a year's salary
could ensure that a dead loved one would
go to
heaven and money could ensure that your
baby your dead child your dead uncle
your dead mother could go to heaven and
if you were Rich enough you could have a
Chantry built and monks would
permanently sing prayers so that that
existence in heaven for the child would
go up and up and up until they were at
the table of the Lord themselves now all
this is in the past and is irrelevant I
seed to an Wham how irrelevant it is
except in one thing this church is
founded on the principle of
intercession only through the apostolic
succession only through the laying on of
hands from this Galilean Carpenter whom
we can all admire only from the laying
on of hands to his Apostles to St Peter
to the other Bishops all the way down to
everyone consecrated in this room anyone
ordained here will know they are uh they
have this extraordinary power to change
the molecules of wine into blood
literally to change the molecules of
paste bread into flesh literally and to
forgive the sins of the peasants and the
poor whom they routinely exploit around
the planet only this church has this
extraordinary principle that it is
through these male priests and only male
priests that this is given it is a
doctrinal fact it is more than a
doctrinal fact it is a Dogma extra
Ecclesia am nul salus outside the church
there is no
salvation that is a dogma of the church
that has been used to excuse all the
missionary Zeal all the rape and torture
of the Aztecs and the incor all the
horrors of South America and Africa and
the Philippines and the rest of the
world to which other churches and other
cultures have also their guilt to admit
it's not unique to the Catholic church
and I never said it was and the motion
doesn't say it was or at least the
opposition of the motion does not
arrogate to the Catholic Church uniquely
this sin however the particular nature
of the exploitation of the poor the
vulnerable and the young if I were to
talk to a priest now believe me that
priest would be the most worldly
Charming
self-deprecating snobbish in a Ronald
Knox Al gilby sort of
way he would be lovely he would smoke
gosh how
daring he would be a sort of ha haa
priest and the Superstition and the
nonsense that we read about of the
church it it's absolute don't pay any
attention Steven just join Farm Street
or one or the bronton oratory and have a
marvelous time as a Catholic and
everything is lovely and Splendid but be
poor and
ignorant and my goodness me every single
detail of damnation and original sin and
of any possibility of your complaining
or asking to think for yourself I said
let's think of this square mile just
imagine in this square mile how many
people were
burned for reading the Bible in English
and one of the principal burners and
torturers of those who tried to read the
Bible in English here in London was
Thomas Moore you may know if you've read
the novel Wolf Hall which won the man
Booker prize just the other day now
that's a long time ago it's not relevant
except that it was only last century
that Thomas Moore was made a saint and
it was only in the year
2000 that the last Pope the pole he he
made Thomas Moore the patron saint of
politicians this is a man who put people
on the rack for daring to own a Bible in
English He tortured them for owning a
Bible in their own language the idea
that the Catholic Church exists to
disseminate the word of the Lord is
nonsense it is the only owner of the
truth for the billions that it likes to
boast about because those billions are
uneducated and poor as again it likes to
boast about but they are the ones it can
tell and Bully and domineer and then we
come to Children Well it's all very well
to say the world didn't know better the
world had no knowledge of how dangerous
crime uh how dangerous a crime child
abuse was I want to read you some of the
words of ratzinger the current pope
staggers me to admit that he is the head
of state of a country incidentally an
Wham said we doesn't have the power of a
nation state yes you do you are a nation
state yes I wrote it down you mentioned
that you are a masan state and it is no
accident that the kyou the UN KIRO
population conference when they were
trying to do something about the world's
population spinning out of control
Vatican City as a nation state
represented at that conference made a
joint statement with the Islamic
countries of the world notably the most
extreme Islamic countries of the world
led by Saudi Arabia and it it began on
behalf of the re revealed religions of
the world dot dot dot and what he did
was essentially hobble and veto any
possibility of women's sexual freedom in
the world because as we know the Islamic
religion and the Catholic Church have
never been anything other than
implacably opposed to women's choice in
their own bodies and their
Destinies
however so
rat Singo in 2003 was he was he was
prefect I'm not making this up he was
prefect of the congregation of the
doctrine of the faith and it was his job
to deal with the child abuse Scandal
that was brewing his First Act was to
write a letter to Catholic Bishops
ordering them on pain of
excommunication not to talk to the
police or anyone else investigation
should be handled he wrote and I'm
quoting that letter in the most
secretive way restrained by Perpetual
silence the Mexican founder of the
Legion of Christ movement marel Deo was
protected from his own catalog of child
abuse which is horrific one cannot put
on trial so close a friend of the Pope
said ratzinger when the allegations
could no longer be denied marel was
sentenced sentenced to a life of prayer
and
penitence and ranzinger described the
whole Affair and that of Bernard La of
Boston to which my colleague also
referred as causing suffering for the
church and for me
personally he also said the answer would
be to stop homosexuals from being
allowed into the church now it's perhaps
unfair of me as a gay man to moan this
enormous institution which is the
largest and most powerful Church on
Earth has over a billion as they like to
tell us members each one of whom is uh
under strict instructions to believe the
dogmas of the church but may wrestle
with them personally of
course it's a little hard for me to know
that I am disordered or again to quote
rat singer um that I'm guilty of a moral
evil uh simply by fulfilling my sexual
Destiny as I see it it's it's hard for
me to be told that be told that I'm I'm
evil because I think of myself as
someone who is filled with love whose
only purpose in life was to achieve love
and who feels love for so much of Nature
and the world and for everything else
and who like anybody decent and of an
education realizes that in order to
achieve and and receive love it's a
struggle it's not one that needs a pope
to tell you how to do it it's certainly
isn't one who needs a pope to tell you
that you're evil with 6% of all teenage
suicides being gay teenage suicides we
certainly don't need the stigmatization
the victimization that leads to the
playground bullying when people say
you're a disordered morally evil
individual that's not nice it isn't
nice the kind of Cruelty in Catholic
Education the kind of of child let's not
call it child abuse it was child rape
the kind of child rape that went on
systematically for so long let's imagine
that we can overlook this and say it is
nothing whatever to do with the
structure and nature of the Catholic
church and the Twisted neurotic and
hysterical way that its leaders are
chosen the celibacy the nuns the monks
the priesthood this is not natural and
normal ladies and gentlemen in
2009 it really
isn't I'm
sorry for me to be called a pervert by
these extraordinarily sexually
dysfunctional people I don't think human
history's ever had
more I have to I have to say this is not
a problem that necessarily is permanent
I like to believe that in 10 years time
I could come back and argue the opposite
even though I've talked about the
history and the structural problems of
this bited institution and the cruelty
and the unpleasantness it is caused
around the world I have yet to approach
one of the subjects dearest to my heart
I've made three documentary films on the
subject of AIDS in Africa my particular
love is the country of Uganda it is one
of the countries I love most in the
world been there many times I've
interviewed Joseph to Yi mevy and his
wife Janet uh before unfortunately she
suddenly saw god um there was a period
when Uganda had the worst incidents of
HIV AIDS in the world I went to raki the
village where it was first spotted but
through an amazing initiative called ABC
abstinence be faithful correct use of
condoms those three I am not denying
that abstinence is a very good way of
not getting AIDS it really is it works
so does being faithful but so do condoms
and do not deny it and this Pope this
Pope not satisfied not satisfied with
saying condoms are against our religion
please consider first abstinence second
being faithful to your partner he
spreads the lie that condoms actually
increase the incident of AIDS he
actually makes sure that Aid is
conditional on saying no to condoms I
have been to there's a hospital in Bundi
in the west of Uganda where I do quite a
lot of work it is unbelievable the pain
and suffering you see now yes yes it is
true abstinence will stop it it's it's
the strange thing about this church it
is obsessed with sex absolutely obsessed
now they will say they will say we with
our permissive society and our rude
jokes are obsessed no we have a health
healthy attitude we like it it's fun
it's jolly because it's a primary
impulse it can be dangerous and dark and
difficult it's a bit like food in that
respect only even more exciting the only
people who are obsessed with food are
anorexics and the morbidly OB beast and
that in erotic terms is the Catholic
church in a
nutshell so
all I want to say really is that we're
here in the Methodist Hall I'm not
trying to argue against religion on this
occasion I'm not saying there's I
understand the desire of anybody to to
seek spiritual rewards in a in a complex
and difficult to understand world we
don't know why we're here where we're
going we want answers we love the idea
of answers how marvelous it would be but
there are other choices there are
Quakers who could possibly quarrel with
a Quaker with their pacifism with their
openness with their ease with their
Simplicity with their refusal to tell
anybody what's a dogma and what isn't
even with methodists also I'm not saying
protestantism is the answer against
Catholicism I am merely saying there are
all kinds of ways we can search for the
truth you do not need this Imperial
panoply of marble and gold do you know
who would be the last person ever to be
accepted as a prince of the church the
Galilean Carpenter that Jew they would
kick him out before he tried to cross
the threshold he would be so ill at ease
in the church that simple and remarkable
man if he said the things that he was
said to have said what would he think
what would he think of St Peter's what
would he think of the wealth and the
power and the self-justification and the
weedling
apologies
what would he think of a man who calls
himself the father a celibate who dared
to lecture people on what family values
are what would he think of any of that
he would be horrified but there is a
solution there is an answer there is
redemption available for all of us and
any one of us and for the Catholic
Church funny enough I think it's a novel
by moris West the pope could decide that
all this power all this wealth this
hierarchy of princes and Bishops and
archbishops and Priests and monks and
nuns could be sent out in the world with
money and art Treasures to put them back
in the countries that they once raped
and violated whose original systems of
animism and belief and simplicity they
told would tell them take them straight
to hell they could give that money away
and they could concentrate on the
apparent essence of their belief and
then I would stand here and say the
Catholic Church May well be a force for
good in the world but until that day it
is
not